in this series on self-directed study in
Philosophy for lifelong Learners or
students who want to learn on their own
things that they're not getting in their
course of studies one of the people that
we really want to Grapple with is
Emmanuel Kant and that is who this video
is about I have been reading and
teaching and and studying and producing
resources on them for a great many years
and so I've got a few ideas about how
you could most profitably approach this
great
philosopher as with all of the other
videos it's kind of broken up into
portions so first we're going to talk
about why K is important in the first
place what you'd get out of studying him
and then we'll look at some practical
questions about con texts and what you
ought to be engaging with I'll give you
some suggestions not only about where to
start but how to keep going and some
idea about why you would want to read
this book as opposed to this book if
you're interested in these particular
issues and what order you might want to
read them in we'll also talk about
useful secondary literature on cont who
is somebody I think you're going to need
to consult someone
and then I've got some advice that is
derived from the format of K Works which
which many people can find quite
challenging including myself I will say
it took me quite some time and I kind of
wish I had uh a helpful guide like this
is trying to provide you with when I
first encountered him and then we'll
talk about some problems and issues that
do arise but which you don't have to
trouble yourself with as you're starting
out studying K they're probably going to
get you into trouble so that's what
we're going to set out in this video and
I hope that it proves useful for
you with any thinker in philosophy it is
a legitimate question and one that
really is worth asking and getting
answers to why should I study this
thinker what am I going to get out of it
or what might I miss out on if I decide
to skip over them and you know K is
acknowledged at least in Western
philosophy as certainly one of the most
important thinkers every once in a while
academic philosophers will put together
lists or do surveys about you know who
is the most important and you know he he
always gets into the top 10 and and
there's good historical re reasons for
that he has been massively
influential really I would say from his
own time except that you know we're
talking about maybe the the later years
of his own time his first critique was
not all that well received it got a lot
of Fairly negative reviews But as time
went on people really recognized how
important he was and Kant has been
important in the same way that some
other thinkers have by people taking up
his ideas and working with them and
reinterpreting them and by people who
think that he's got things not
absolutely completely wrong but pretty
much wrong and responding to him
criticizing him so that that's a sign
that he's somebody well worth engaging
in and I'll say this so he's been
massively influential on the the
movement that he is an early part of
German
idealism uh um he winds up being very
important in Continental philosophy
that's European philosophy more broadly
influences classical American philosophy
influences um quite a few uh thinkers
and and submovements within
anglo-american and also you know
Scandinavian uh analytic philosophy and
there's even other you could say strains
of philosophy who are responding to in
one way or another so in the toist
Spectrum we talk about transcendental
tomis well that's in part a reaction to
a postc conscien world and so there's he
has a massive influence and it it would
be understandable if you thought well I
need to study this guy just because I
want to study other people later down
the line who are responding to him or
influenced by him I think there's some
other reasons why you would want to
study Kant as well besides this issue of
influence one is he's offering us a
really interesting well
constructed perhaps even in Parts true
system of
philosophy that is attempting to like a
lot of people before him sort of like
Begin Again the
philosophical project so you know he's
he's not just confined to one area like
some philosophers just do ethics or
epistemology Kant is really trying to
connect not only do but connect it all
up together and to do so in some sort of
thought out coherent way and so even if
you don't buy his system which a lot of
us don't do you can certainly find
something to admire in the project
itself in the ambition and in the um
structure and consistency
of that you may even find an Elegance or
beauty I some people may say whoa that's
the wrong term but you may even find
that in some of the constructions of
that and I will say this so Kant I'm not
going to lie to you is a difficult
thinker to read and understand it does
get better and easier as you go on but
sometimes that takes quite a while still
there is a certain whatever you want to
call it Joy satisfaction
appreciation involved when you figure
out what the hell this guy is actually
saying and what the universe what US
human beings you know what other things
would actually look like if he happen to
be right about these matters and and so
I think that there's you know there's a
joy in figuring this out um he's
certainly going to make you work for it
and Kant is uh still massively important
even in present day
ethics in
Aesthetics in you know to a lesser
extent in political Theory um but he's
also a major reference point for
metaphysics and epistemology and a lot
of his ideas are you know so now part of
you could call it the the uh sphere of
philosophy that you may have encountered
some of them without even realizing it
and you'll even find speculative fiction
writers referencing him a prime example
is if you ever read The Works of Philip
K dick you will find characters who
themselves have read K thinking about
some of the implications of Emmanuel
kant's philosophy with respect to space
and time and subjectivity so you know
it's it's it's worth digging into this
guy I want to say one other thing and
this is sort of a footnote so I did a
video uh some time back about texts with
aura as I called them and kant's first
critique the critique of pure reason is
one of those texts that it's kind of
floating out there in Internet land
people think oh this is the book I must
read because if I do I'll understand
everything and so it gets a lot of press
this is only one of K's books really
important book but only one of them and
it doesn't cover
everything and you know it is rewarding
to read it and understand it it takes a
lot of work but you know just like with
uh hegel's phenomenology of spirit or
Spinoza's ethics if you invest it with
that
much affectivity on your own those hopes
and desires you might be a little bit
let down so I do want to caution you
about that and then let's move on to
talking about some of the nitty-gritty
of K's
texts so there's a number of practical
questions that people are going to have
and actually raise in uh internet forums
about studying Kant and you know the
first one understandably is well what
text do I need to start with I just
mentioned you don't start with a
critique of pure reason um even though
that can be quite attractive and I'll
tell you why in just a little bit when I
give you my own suggestions about where
to start another really big issue that
people are going to bring up is well
which translations do I need to get
which is the best translation and you
know there isn't absolute
consensus about which translations are
the best ones just to you know again
bring up the critique of pure reason so
you know two popular ones that I have
are uh Norman Kemp Smith's uh Edition
which for a long time was used as kind
of the standard and you know it's it's
good it's quite readable um it's
actually according to you know lore
that's out there a lot of German
students would actually use this because
they found the translation easier to
understand than K German
um Cambridge has a very nice addition uh
they have a whole bunch of nice
additions as well this one is translated
by Guyer and and wood um it's a little
bit more recent you know and you know
which of these is the best you know it
depends on what you're looking for you
know at this point at the very beginning
I wouldn't worry about having the
definitive translation I would say get
yourself a a translation and if you want
to you can easily find more than one of
many of the important works and you can
compare them with each other if you
can't read German obviously you can't go
to the original text which is what I do
as soon as I find a translation sounding
a little weird or I want to know exactly
what's being said there um but that's
not that big of an impediment and I
don't think you need to let it hold you
back
um one thing that that you should be
aware of because there are different
translations is that the names of The
Works themselves May differ from each
other but they're still the same work so
for example I usually talk about the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
you notice this one this particular
translation the fundamental principles
of the metaphysics and morals they're
both fine they're both the same book but
you know they're going to be talked
about in different ways sometimes times
we'll refer to the first critique the
second critique the third critique and
what we mean there is the critique of
pure reason the critique of practical
reason the critique of judgment they're
the same things so don't let that screw
you up um where do I need to start we're
going to get to that in just a minute
because that's uh kind of uh you know
tricky and I do have some some thoughts
about that but then how much do I need
to read so so in order to
adequately understand K is it enough
just to read say the groundwork for the
metaphysics and morals for the ethics
and the proma to any future metaphysics
and then maybe a few other things that's
going to be better than nothing but it's
not going to be all of what you might
want to read but do you need to read
everything that K wrote obviously not
there's some things that are more
Central than others and again we'll talk
about what those are and why in just a
second so I want to dissuade you from
the idea that you have to have read
everything that an author has said uh or
else you don't understand them and with
Kant there's two things that I want to
convey to you so first of all sometimes
it can be useful to read an author's
earlier Works before they wrote the big
things that they're really well known
for with Kant we call this the
precritical phase of his philosophy
because according to Kant he was awoken
from a dogmatic Slumber by reading the
works of David Hume that's probably true
you know I mean sometimes our memories
and our stories about ourselves are a
little bit embellished maybe that's the
case with with Kant um but he certainly
is very explicitly reacting to David
Hume and even you know I won't say
thanking him but ackn knowledging him at
particular points in his work um you
don't really need to read the
pre-critical stuff unless you're going
to be a k scholar very few people
actually do read those those works so
I'm going to kind of put those to a side
the other thing that I've been thinking
about and this has to do with like how
you
read K is somebody who when you read
you're consuming and you really got to
let yourself digest you don't want to be
trying to speedread through any of these
things that's popular among people who
want to brag about how many books
they've read they haven't actually read
in in any real sense most of the books
that they've read and and gone through
Kant is somebody who's working
systematically methodically with complex
ideas that really have to do with like
the fundamentals of space time
Consciousness you know uh what a human
being is how we're connected to each
other what the universe is this is stuff
that you got to kind of take your time
with and so you know when you're you're
reading you should actually expect that
you're probably going to need to not
just read but reread and allow things to
make sense to you you more and more over
time and now is that a practical
question about the text it is it's one
that you didn't know that you needed to
ask how should I read K and the answer
is well fairly slowly and with the
expectation that you're going to have to
probably go backwards into the text and
um you know compare things with each
other this this slow process of building
so I think those are enough of the
initial practical questions that are
likely to arise for somebody who is
approaching k for the first time or
maybe after uh a lack of success for the
first time and coming back to
K so my suggestions about how to start
and this may seem a little controversial
or counterintuitive to some people who
already have ideas about what they want
to do and what they
uh have heard is the right way to go
with K I'm not putting myself forward as
like the only expert on uh
self-directed study or pedagogy with K
but I I'll tell you what I think
probably works and then we'll talk about
where do you go after that so not just
where to start but how to continue
studying KH I'm going to
recommend three Works to start with and
two of these are works that I have
developed resources on and I've taught
to classes and students and you know
they're sort of the beginning places for
studying Emmanuel Kant and they're not
the critique of pure reason um that
comes later so I would say there's two
works out there um which
are you know they're not beginner level
work but they are at least a bit more
approachable than the rest of the the
field that we're going into so one of
these I've already mentioned the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
or the fundamental principles of the
metaphysics of morals Kant did write a
metaphysics of morals and that's an
important work that's going to come
about later on um this is often taught
by itself in ethics classes as like you
know here's what we're going to get of
of Kant
and then there's the proliga to any
future metaphysics and you could say
that the the um groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals has the same or
similar relation to the rest of the
moral philosophy that the proma does to
the theoretical or speculative or um
epistemological metaphysical philosophy
that you're going to find in the first
critique and Kant actually wrote the
first critique and then wrote the proma
after that now the
proma is going to present you with a lot
of K basic
ideas on um space and time
perception uh the you know the the
difference between the um uh synthetic
and the analytic and op priori and a
posteriori and um he's going to talk
about
pure mathematics pure Natural Science
and then
metaphysics as three different
disciplines which we can actually make
some progress with and he's going to
introduce us to what he calls the
dialectic of pure
reason um which we'll we'll talk about
maybe a little bit as we go into the
secondary literature but it's it's an
important idea and then you know what we
can actually make progress with so he's
introducing it to his his critical or
transcendental method in this and you
know something similar is happening in
the uh fundamental uh or the groundwork
for the metaphysics of morals he's
setting out his ethical perspective he's
criticizing other perspectives he's
trying to show where they go wrong and
one thing that I do like about both of
these works is he's going to provide you
with some useful examples that you can
you can wrap your head around to to try
to understand what it is that he's
saying so these two good starting points
and then I would actually
suggest beginning with a third work but
it's not a single work it's actually
this collection which you can get from
hackit very inexpensively there's like a
million copies floating around out there
I may be exaggerating AIT a bit but you
know uh there are a lot of these because
it it it often gets uh used for
University classes and and it's uh you
know it's labeled Perpetual peace and
other essays and Perpetual peace is one
of those um essays it's actually the
sixth one there but there's some other
ones in there that are quite important
as well about um Universal history um
about his ethics on the proverb that may
be true in theory but it's of no
practical use and another really really
important uh essay what is Enlightenment
kind is understood to be an
Enlightenment thinker we have an
Enlightenment thinker telling us what he
thinks Enlightenment actually consistent
so and this is these are more
approachable let's say than the proma or
the groundwork um they are still kind of
technical there's some jargon in there
we're going to talk about that in just a
bit but um they give you a nice flavor
for what con project and ideas are at
least certain aspects of it then you've
got uh other directions you can go you
know after I think you've read through
those and you've you've adequately
digested them well if you want to go to
the first critique notice that both of
these copies this this is a long long
work right um maybe you're up for it
plan that you're going to take a lot of
time and the the critique of reason is
you know covering
epistemology metaphysics also what we
would call uh certain aspects of
philosophy of religion um some things
that figure into philosophical
anthropology and there's a lot of
Engagement not only with kant's own own
ideas and system but with previous
thinkers in philosophy so this will take
you a while but the critique of pure
reason quite rewarding to make your way
through and to understand um I'm
actually myself
personally a bigger fan of kant's moral
philosophy and so the second critique
and notice quite a bit shorter the
critique of practical reason if you've
read the groundwork for the metaphysics
and morals there's no reason that you
can't read the critique of practical
reason
which is doing something similar to the
first critique but now for ethics uh
moral philosophy and to a certain extent
philosophy of human nature and it's uh
well worth uh studying and and reading
your way through I think you will find
it quite rewarding and then we have the
actual metaphysics of
morals and there's no reason that if
you've read the groundwork which is the
Preparatory piece you shouldn't go on to
the actual metaphysics and morals which
is divided into two parts I I've
actually got two different texts here to
you know as props the metaphysical
elements of Justice which is essentially
political social philosophy but it's K's
ethical philosophy in its application in
that field and then um this is another
hacket Edition merely labeled ethical
philosophy but what it really is is the
metaphysical elements of of virtue and
that is where Kant gets even deeper into
his ethics and we'll actually talk about
virtues which is quite interesting
because you know frankly there's a bit
of a side note um consan deontological
ethics is often contos to Virtue ethics
but K like many people in his time did
talk about virtue uh where do you go
from from there
well why not check out the third
critique and notice again we got a big
old book here and this is a this is a
challenging work just as much as the
first critique is this is about
Aesthetics the conception of beauty
taste judgments that we make and the
notion of teleology or purposiveness so
this is going to involve you know
artwork work but also nature and human
nature and uh you know touch on aspects
of religion as well so this is a really
interesting work well worth getting into
um it's also people talk about the
sublime that's where you're going to
find Kant talking about that and then
there's uh two other works that I I'd
like to bring up that you may find
yourself being attracted to and one of
these you know kind of straddles these
projects it's called religion within the
limits of reason alone and it's K's
philosophy of religion which figures
partly in you could say engagement with
the first critique um ties into some
things in the third critique but is
mostly about ethics so it figures into
the moral philosophy you know the notion
of radical evil get it's uh brought up
and you know religion is thought of
largely in ethical terms and then
another text that I find particularly
interesting and you may as well the
anthropology from a pragmatic point of
view now these are
lectures that were um you know published
as a a work a very systematic work and
it's looking at human nature and uh
what's going on with that how can we
understand ourselves and it's really
looking at what what kind of calls The
Faculty of desire which plays a very
important role has some important
sociopolitical implications there are
other lectures that you can find out
there um you know lectures on
philosophical theology for example if
you're interested in the philosophy of
religion or the logic or or metaphysics
and but that's the stuff that you should
read way down the line I think to work
your way through the the three critiques
and the related materials and those
Preparatory stuff you're talking about
probably a period of a couple years so
you don't need to worry so much about
which lectures do I need to read after
that so that's all primary
texts what about secondary
literature if you've watched my videos
or interacted with me you know that I'm
not a fan of going right to secondary
literature uh in order to understand
things I want people to primary texts
that said I think with K in particular
can be quite helpful to read and make
use of secondary literature just as you
would a good friend who actually has
read this stuff and understands it or a
teacher who's who's you know well-versed
in K and I'm going to tell you about
some of the secondary literature is a
vast field so obviously I'm not going to
touch on all of it but I'll give you my
my take and I'll put a couple
interesting things in front of you to
begin with there are some good uh
encyclopedia entries out there on Con in
the Internet Encyclopedia philosophy and
the Stanford encyclopedia philosophy so
those are free resources you can easily
get uh when it comes to K's ethics we
should mention onora O'Neal As an
interpreter of Kant there's others out
there who to take K's work and adapt it
interestingly in business ethics Norman
Bowie is the guy who coined the phrase
as far as I know consan capitalism and
he does business ethics from a very
persuasive conscien point of view so you
can easily find his works I've done some
some lectures on him and now let's talk
about um resources that you might turn
to so one popular thing would be let's
situate Kant within the history of
philosophy and I've got a few to bring
up to you uh some of which I don't
recommend and I'll tell you why and some
of which I I do recommend so you know
very popular book you'll find all over
the place Bert and Russell's history of
Western
philosophy um he's not the most
sympathetic reader of Kant you know he
will say for example is in the beginning
of
it um the critique of knowledge as a
means of reaching philosoph IAL
conclusions is emphasized by a Kant and
accepted by his followers there's an
emphasis on mind as opposed to matter
which leads in the end to the assertion
that only mind exists so bing bing bing
alarm Bells go off already there because
Kant doesn't say that um there's a
vehement rejection of utilitarian ethics
in favor of systems which are held to be
demonstrated by abstract philosophical
arguments utilitarian ethics wasn't
around when Kant was writing there's a
Scholastic tone which is absent in the
earlier French and English
philosophers well no that's not true
either so I mean this should tell you I
don't know if this guy knows what he's
talking about and you're G to find that
there isn't that much here right it's
only uh uh a matter so he begins uh on
page
um here we go uh 701 and finishes up on
page 718 not enough to really learn
about Kant um a recent history
philosophy AJ AJ Greeling um which is
you know a bit better um starts out with
here's a claim that few which who are
knowledgeable about philosophy would
dispute the three greatest figures in
the history of Western philosophy are
Plato Aristotle and Kant so you read
that and you're like that's pretty good
you know he really likes Kant doesn't he
and um it's it's not bad it's you know
telling you a little bit about the guy
and his uh uh you know history and um
you know centering him in this but
you're not going to get very much of K's
actual teaching in this uh so again page
256 to page 268 12 Pages not that much
what would be a good contrast uh you
know it's hard to go wrong with
Friedrich cbl's history of philosophy uh
he devotes if I remember right five
chapters of this particular no six uh
volume two seven actually because he
talks about the the Opus postumum um uh
to to K himself and you know you can see
that it is a pretty substantial part of
this this particular volume and you know
cobblestone was writing this for
students this is what we would uh use as
beginning points back back in graduate
school and so you know if you want
something it's still hard to surpass in
histories of philosophy uh Cobblestone a
couple other ones that I think might be
of interest so McIntyre is a short
history of Ethics actually has a uh
chapter uh on K and you know I I think
it's it's also rather short it's
centered just on uh ethics and social
political philosophy uh and I think that
it's you know it's it's decent um
there's actually an interesting essay in
this volume history of political
philosophy uh but edited by Leo Strauss
and Joseph
cropsy and uh this is kind of nice
because it talks it's pretty substantive
talking about 40 pages or so about
kant's um the implications of of kant's
philosophy for politics and Kant did
write a lot about history a lot about um
Society so you know that that's that's
pretty good couple others that I'll
recommend in terms of History stuff so
Terry Pinker has this very very nice
book German philosophy 1760 to 1860 the
legacy of idealism Kant is right there
in the middle and of course massively
influential on on all the stuff that's
coming later pinker's a good scholar two
so uh worth checking out and then I
cannot recommend this book highly enough
the late schne winds uh the invention of
autonomy and why did he write this book
in the first place so he tells us in the
preface I started on the work work that
led to this book because there were many
aspects of kant's moral philosophy I
could not understand I thought I would
have a better chance of understanding
them if I knew what questions Kant
believed he had to answer when he began
considering
the subject right and the the explicit
discussion of Kant isn't until the end
uh page
508 but it's you know it's it's a really
substantive engagement and it gives you
a lot of background on thinkers that are
leading up to K and this idea of
autonomy um now we get into some other
things that might be good
resources so you know some
representative books Kant a guide for
the perplexed by Sun and Kant by Allan
uh W wood H you know you can get things
like this it's kind of hard to they they
are more readable than Kant himself they
are good in taking K ideas and putting
them into relation perspective with each
other uh a very interesting book along
those lines is by uh WK wh verme
cun the architectonic and development of
his philosophy you want a uh
systematic discussion of and how
his philosophy is developing and what's
going on in it this this is a good book
for that I can I can recommend it um
something else that's a little bit
misnamed that I thought you know as I
was looking around for resources there
is this thing called a cont dition AR
which you will find in various uh mostly
University libraries uh Howard K kill
and this is part of the Blackwell
philosopher dictionaries it's not a
dictionary it is uh instead something
like an encyclopedia right so here's the
first entry a a priori a posterior and
you notice that the explanation of it
goes on for three and a half pages
that's exactly what you want you don't
want just you know up a priori one line
about it you want an explanation so I
think that glossies or encyclopedias
that can be very helpful with k um the
last two books that I'm going to mention
in terms of secondary lit you've seen
these before Cambridge companions they
uh bring together a bunch of people
actually some of whom in this one I
actually know um and they uh you know
write on particular topics so K
intellectual development the
transcendental aesthetic um you know
vindicating reason great great piece in
here by or onora O'Neal autonomy
obligation and virtue an overview of K's
moral philosophy schne wind right so
this is this is kind of nice you're
getting like really good K Scholars who
can write to a general audience a
general General educated audience
explaining it and then we've got this
Paul grave C handbook and you notice
this is about twice the size so it's
going to cover topics with essays that
aren't being talked about in some of
these other ones so for
example um you know sort of very
practical application how a Kanan
decides what to do by Alan wood um K and
sexuality very interesting set of issues
by Helga
Varden um you know proper science and
empirical laws count on faith religious
ascent and limits to knowledge um count
mature theory of punishment right that's
kind of a an interesting article there
count on emotions feelings and
affectivity so this might be good for
you but I would recommend if you're
going to do secondary Works those you
know encyclopedia entries sort of basic
stuff maybe the
glossery um some of the things that
situate K in history and then later
after you've read some k then go to
those essays um and see if they help you
put things into perspective so that's a
lot of advice I've thrown at you um I'll
just reiterate where do you start well
with the proma the groundwork and then
those um those selected essays that you
can find in the volume Perpetual piece
and other essays
I got a good bit of advice for you that
has to do with the format or we could
say the style of K works so the good
news is this they're systematic right he
is advancing from topic to Topic in a
way that he thinks makes the most sense
the best way to present stuff is it
always the best well you know this
varies from reader to reader and also
from time to time but you won't have you
won't have Kant just like throwing ideas
out there willy-nilly and then you have
to put them all together he's done the
putting it together for you that's the
good news the bad news is K writes in
something that I like to when I'm
explaining it to students I like to call
it the code because students read it and
I have undergraduates reading Emmanuel
Kant and they're not philosophy majors
and they they pick up and they start
reading the book and they're like what
the hell is this and then we talk about
it in class so you know jargon like
transcendental what is the relation
between that and Transcendent or
aesthetic right or uh opior a posteriori
or uh synthetic uh analytic all of these
jargon things heteronomy what do these
mean well again there's a good news bad
news the bad news is that Kant is
using all of this stuff all the time
because it's his technical language the
good news is once you've actually
figured out what the hell he's saying
and means by these terms and very often
he'll give you
explanations you can decode it and you
can sort of translate it in your mind
and figure it out and then you
understand what he's actually saying
there's one other bad piece of bad news
sometimes these terms are used in some
what different ways by Kant than they
are by later philosophers who used
kant's terminology and twisted it in
different ways so you want to look at
how Kant is actually using the term but
he's not the first to use all of these
terms AR priori a posterior long
established I mean going back to Thomas
aquinus it's there in Hume right so
those those are are just fine um and and
very often as I mentioned Kant will give
you partial explanations at least of
what he means so that's one thing
another thing to keep in mind that may
be very very helpful is that Kant
understands the human being in terms of
what he calls faculties or capabilities
ways in which we get things or are moved
or act or things like that so you know
sensibility Zite is the lowest and and
you know then we have the understanding
and this is where we get like the
categories coming in and all that and
all of that works together uh and and
interacts with the world that we
encounter then we have the faculty of
Reason Fair n as opposed to Fan which is
understanding and that's something
distinctively human which interacts or
interfaces with these others we also
have like a faculty of Desire we you
know we could go on and on and on about
that but a lot of what Kant is doing is
you know makes it difficult to
understand once you see that these are
kind of layered onto each other and and
as I said interfacing with each other
and interacting the picture gets a lot
clearer right so he's going to use these
terms consistently throughout his work
so that's another piece of of good news
for you all often tell my students that
the two biggest obstacles to them
understanding are the code which
hopefully I help them with and then this
let's call it does he really mean that
sort of
incredulity that comes with things I
mean Kant for example thinks that
morality must be absolutely Universal
and exceptionless or it's no good uh and
it would be like really he he really
thinks that consequences don't matter at
all yeah he really thinks that as a
matter of fact I'll mention as a side
note that's one of the things that jacqu
laah in his uh his seminar on the ethics
of psychoanalysis actually Praises Kant
for he says wow Kant brought into our
discourse something that hadn't really
been said before holy crap you know he
he articulated something quite
interesting there
so you know that's another thing that
you might want to keep in mind um the
other things that I want to say about
Kant I want to stress again that you got
to read him slowly you cannot skip steps
with k or skim or speedread and hope to
get much out of it and if it takes you
what feels to you like a longer time
than you wanted to put in that's just
the way it is and you know you may have
to readjust your reading schedule or
your expectations about what you're
going to do I also want to say that in
K's Works you're going to see him
approaching the same
topics sometimes in new ways so you know
just as a an example the proliga and the
first critique they go together but K
says I'm presenting things this way and
proma this way in the uh first critique
uh I mentioned uh religion within the
limits of reason alone is also a work of
Ethics so the moral philosophy stuff is
getting treated again in that work
anthropology from a pragmatic point of
view a lot of ideas that were previously
raised get get um reconsidered in there
so that's that's important to keep in
mind as
well uh what else um I think that um
with Kant don't feel bad about using
secondary literature um don't substitute
reading secondary literature for
actually reading K but it's perfectly
fine to go to you know the K dictionary
and see what these terms mean uh or to
read other people's takes on what Kant
is saying again Cobblestone not going to
steer you wrong uh might be very helpful
for for understanding what Kant is
saying and how the parts fit together
and why why Kant is so important to to
read and the last thing that I'll say I
brought this up a little bit earlier K
will give you
examples focus on those examples realize
that they are just examples not the
totality of what it is that he's
teaching but that he's giving you a gift
in providing you with these examples
examples and you as an active reader
should try to come up with your own
examples so great example of this in the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
he is going to present you with several
different examples for how to apply the
different formulations of the
categorical imperative at least the
first and second
formulation um come up with your own
this is what we do in classes by the way
and in assignments come up with your own
examples and then
apply what Kant is saying to that if
you're trying to think about space and
time and Mathematics and geometry and
you know enough about those those things
see if I can come up with some examples
that work for that for you and that will
help you to better wrap your head around
this difficult set of ideas that K is
proposing to you so maybe that will be
helpful uh as you approach K
works there are a number of issues that
you could easily get caught up on and
snagged on and think about too much and
they'll keep you from making the kind of
progress in understanding Emmanuel Kant
and his works that you want to make and
studying so I'm not going to say that
these aren't important or they're not
real issues but I would caution you
against giving them too much space in
your head don't worry over much about
them so the number one thing don't worry
about whether Kant has everything right
before you get caught up in that
especially if it's some minutia like you
know Kant is saying this but I think it
has to be this way well if you're going
to do that it's sort of like stopping
the conversation right at the beginning
and if you want to understand what Kant
is saying you you got to give him some
leeway you got to give him some headp
space so to speak imagine that he's
actually got things correct um and also
if you think if you're coming right out
of the gate and you think that K
basically has things wrong that's
probably because you're approaching him
with a whole bunch of assumptions of
your own and a very rigid
Manner and that's not a good way to read
any philosopher that's going to get you
into trouble so I would I would worry
about you know deciding whether you
think K is correct or not until you you
I won't say have understand the entire
totality of his system but at least
understand big parts then then you can
start to worry about that and um you
know similar issue arises well what
about kant's own assumptions you know
he's assuming a
Newtonian uh you know ukian approach to
time and space and you could say yeah of
course cuz he's a creature of his time I
mean you can say something similar about
Aristotle and Aristotle's uh physical
Theory you know K could have some basic
assumptions wrong um he also didn't know
an awful lot about people out in the
world you know outside of Central Europe
he he just you know read about them in
different ways um so you know he he's
not working from a great knowledge base
or experiential base that doesn't
nullify what it is that he's saying it
just contextualizes it right so you
don't have to say well you know he's
he's from an earlier time how could he
possibly understand anything read his
stuff and see what he actually has to
say that will be more profitable to you
um worrying about whether Kant is
entirely fair to the the people that
he's
criticizing I don't think you have to
worry about that at this point in time
um is he right in you know criticizing
Renee deart or anom of Canterbury or you
know bishop barkle or this person or
that person again see what he has to say
figure out that and then actually read
those people and then you can decide
whether Kant has them correct or not or
whether he's creating Straw Men but
that's not something that you should
worry about at the beginning of studying
Kant um and then you know also you can
ask
yourself how do I know if I'm actually
getting it or I kind of feel like I'm
not getting it um okay so that's a sign
that you probably need to to either back
up and reapo it with fresh eyes and a
fresh mind or that maybe you're making
progress maybe maybe some of the things
that we talked about just a little bit
earlier like does he really believe this
that this claim that he's making yes he
really believes it it takes a little
while for you to wrap your head around
that and understand it yourself that's
that's fine that's the way we make
progress
um and then the last thing that I don't
want you to worry about right now has to
do not so much with K and more to do
with other thinkers so if I want read
Hegel do I have to fully understand K do
I at least have to have gone through the
critique of pure reason no you don't
have to I mean do you have to have read
David hume's inquiry concerning human
understanding to be able to understand
k no I mean it helps right but it it's
not as if these things work like uh
courses that are set in a rigid
progression that develop like that
that's not the way philosophy actually
works and anybody who tries to tell you
that they're not they don't have your
best interest in mind and they're
probably wrong themselves so you know if
you're reading Kant it's enough to
struggle with his thought and his text
you don't need to worry about whether
this is going to be absolutely necessary
for understanding Hegel or schopenhauer
or anybody else who references Emmanuel
MOX shayer for example right or
Fredick nche um it's enough just to
focus on your task at hand without
bringing in all this extra baggage that
just kind of clutters up your your
workroom that you're studying within so
that's the things I'd like you to avoid
worrying
about well this turned out to be quite a
long video turned out that there was a
lot to say about this great thinker
Emanuel Kant My Hope Is that you will
take the things in this that are useful
for you you might actually as you're
going through and engaging in study of
maybe you come back to this and see
whether there was anything that was said
that you might have missed the first
time that turned out to be useful or
that you know you you tried and I was
wrong about right so uh take this all
with the proverbial grain of salt but
you know I have been reading kind I
struggled with him at the very beginning
as a matter of fact I'm going to close
this by telling you a little story about
my own
background I you know I I was a
philosophy major in college and I took a
modern philosophy class as you typically
do and it you know begins with Renee
dayart and then uh ours actually ended
with with Kant if I remember correctly
and we read the
proma and I understood bits of it and
other bits I was like what the hell is
this I don't I don't know what what
they're saying here and um unfortunately
I didn't have a good set of professors
who were interested in philosophy to
explain that stuff to me and so you know
I read some summaries about Kant and
that kind of helped me so secondary
literature but I I didn't really
understand Kant until I got to graduate
school I mean I I I the ethical
philosophy had gotten in dribs and drabs
I hadn't read the groundwork till I got
to grad school and was uh required to
read cun in a variety of different um
classes bits and pieces and then to
prepare for my preliminary examinations
and and the comprehensive examinations I
had to read a lot of this K stuff right
and it took me a while it's going to
take you a while too that's okay doesn't
mean you're dumb it doesn't mean that
you're not applying yourself it just
means you're engaging with difficult
material it was hard for me it's going
to be hard for you but I will say that
if you do put the time in you will find
it even if you don't agree with Kant I
don't you will find it enjoyable and
rewarding at some point so on that I
will close and I hope that this proves
helpful for you and it encourages you to
study the works of Emmanuel
Kant